Comment allez vous ?
On est retourné en 2008 avec cette intro ! Écoutez les amis aujourd'hui je suis tout excité, pourquoi ?
Parce que, hier j'ai reçu le mail d'un abonné me conseillant le site :
Craig, craigl, je savais que j'allais avoir du mal à le dire...
Craigslist, put*in c'est chiant...
Le site craigslist qu'est-ce que c'est ? C'est un mixe en gros entre leboncoin, Viva Street, Rue Du Commerce, bref il y a un peu de tout.
En gros c'est des annonces mais ça peut concerner tout et n'importe quoi.
Il y a une partie : "Best Of" sur craigslist qui regroupe les annonces les plus improbables qu'il y a sur le site
et vue qui c'est un site qui est essentiellement utilisé aux États-Unis, en France c'est plus leboncoin.
Et bah comme vous le savez aux États-Unis ils font tous en plus gros, plus grand, plus large, plus loin dans le délire.
Donc les annonces ça va être un peu pareil c'est en anglais au montage bien évidemment on traduira en français pour votre plus grand plaisir
moi je vais faire
l'interprète de qualité ! Comme vous l'avez vus dans la dernière vidéo "tu coupes la moitié de la jambe d'une araignée combien de jambes
va-t-il rester à l'araignée?" *tape sur le clavier*
je sais parfaitement lire tout ce qui est en anglais. Alors premièrement une professionnelle
*rigole *
Une entraîneuse professionnelle de Pokémon Go, 20 dollars l'heure, mec c'est archi cher c'est incroyable : "à propos de moi j'ai 24 ans et j'adore Pokémon,
et je veux vous aider vous ! à devenir le meilleur dresseur !" C'est génial, je trouve ça fantastique.
"Personnellement je suis un entraîneur de niveau 15 dans Pokémon Go", c'est nul en plus je crois ... "J'ai actuellement un Iphone 6S
plusieurs chargeurs de portables et je suis en très bonne forme physiquement marcher plusieurs heures n'est pas un problème.
Je me connecterai avec votre compte et je ferai comme si c'est le mien je les attraperai tous chaque échange
débutera par une consultation au pokestop le plus proche".
Mec c'est génial comme rendez vous "je sais comment me défendre donc pas de bullshit avec moi" putain la meuf elle met les points sur les I.
Écoute Ivy StIve quand tu veux je te file mon téléphone est vraiment pour 20 $ l'heure en plus c'est vraiment rentables c'est ça qui est bien
ça veut dire qu'en trois heures j'aurais pu m'acheter de Pokémon soleil sur ma DS et jouer sans avoir à bouger de chez moi en plus !
Mais bon c'est mignon, alors une vieille poupée allemande des années 1800
Oh mec, c'est glauque "as f*ck" c'est quoi ce délire? J'ai vu la poupée Annabelle en vrai y'a pas longtemps mais je vous jure qu'à côté de ça
Annabelle mais qu elle était gentille tu invites au resto sans aucun problème
mec j'ai jamais vu une poupée aussi creepy sa mère mais attends ça quoi c'est un bol en fait derrière son crâne c'est le matin pour manger des céréales sans déconner ?
Oh putain le mec dans la description il ose dire "joli visage quoi..".
Mec désolé mais ça c'est pas du tout un joli visage, c'est un visage qui va te hanter pendant de nombreuses années...
"l'arrière de la tête est endommagée" ah donc c'est pas normal ça... *rires*
je sais pas quel enfant elle a eu entre les mains mais c'était un p*tain de psychopathe !
Allez, ça dégage, ah y m'a mis mal. Cet homme vend 99 bouteilles de bière, vides ! Voilà !
Mais il a la gentillesse de nous dire à quoi ça peut servir :
"j'ai collectionné 99 bouteilles de bière unique ces dernières années mais j'ai finalement atteint mon but et je suis prêt à passer à autre chose, les faire recycler ou les confier à une bonne personne.
Si vous planifiez un voyage au Michigan et que vous voulez obtenir un taux de rendement incroyable de 9,90 dollars sur votre investissement de recyclage c'est l'offre qu'il vous faut !!"
Mais c'est gentil ça ! Il pense à nous
Ah je savais pas qu'au Michigan tu pouvais recyclé une bouteille vide de bière et on te filait 10 centimes,
voilà c'est une info peu utiles. "Elles font de très bonnes munitions pour les combats dans les bars. Je vous le confirme,
elles se cassent très facilement comme des bouteilles normale et vous pourrez parfaitement frappé la tête de quelqu'un avec"
Notes:  en vrai ne le faite pas. Il est génial ce mec, ce mec est génial j'ai envie de lui acheter, mec ! Il est si fort qu'on a
envie de lui acheter ses bouteilles de bière vides ! c'est fou. Pet spyder
qu'est ce que c'est que ça je cherche une nouvelle maison pour ma petite araignée
elle a récemment perdu son ami elle se retrouve seule et dépressive elle est facile à garder et très silencieuse je la donnerai seulement à
une personne sérieuse envoyez moi un message si vous êtes interessés
C'est horrible parce que quand il te dit : "elle a perdu son ami elle est seule et dépressive" put*in j'ai envie de rire alors que c'est
horrible quoi ça se trouve c'est vrai. Ah elle est mignonne en plus.
Au put*in de sa mère, elle fait peur ! Regarde c'est grande... Olala oui oui ça dégage !
C'est nul à ch*er comme objet : hoverboard kart. Ohhh il est moche
Oh, Attend, c'est trop stylé en vraie, je retire ce que je viens de dire. Mec, il s'est gavé il a fait un put*in de traineau avec un hoverboard à l'avant mec,
c'est un p*utin d'ingénieur en vraie ! Tu t'assois là et à même une petite place pour un sac derrière ou une glacière mais je veux me déplacer dans ce
véhicule
"ce kart scooter unique est impressionnant et sûr d'attirer l'attention" mais clairement vraiment "utiliser le pour naviguer vers votre trou de pêche ou votre camping
préféré sans avoir à trimballer tout votre matériel" je veux l'acheter prenez ma tune ! Je veux aller au bureau avec ça mec je suis scotché
Ohhhh, Got Damn It
Une Potato, il vend une putain de patate
il l'a laissée combien de temps germer?! c'est un scandale vieux ... "pendant mon nettoyage de printemps je nettoyais une armoire et j'y ai trouvé à l'arrière une
patate
je me suis senti triste de la retirer de la parce qu'elle a fait une telle preuve de combativité
si vous avez une cour ou un jardin et que vous seriez prêts à prendre soin de cette patate
contactez moi j'espère que vous serez capable de lui fournir une grande maison aimante et un sol fertile à cultiver"
Put*in, les gens ils ont l'art de vendre des choses, des trucs nul
il a fait un si beau discours j'ai envie de l'adopter cette patate, enfaite je me suis trompé en allant chercher Natsu au Japon mec, il
y avait tout aussi mignon pas loin quoi. Alors oh là là ça va être creepy ça
Oh arrêtez avec vos put*in de poupées. Des poupées pour ventriloques. Oh mec, elles sont creepy... il faut vraiment arrêter
C'est de pire en pire chaque nouvelle photo est pire que la précédente
oh là là regardez le lui dirai qu'il est pas sur la photo de base
Je suis sur le mec il a pris la photo et il a fait ; "mais j'ai pas et poupées que ce qu'elle fait là?" il me dit quoi
le mec fait vos offres je les échange contre des vieux trucs
Godzilla, des lunch box, des guitares ou à peu près tout ce que vous avez ! Un x wing fait maison
mec s'est trop bien ! "Mon fils s'est cassé la jambe et a dû être en fauteuil roulant pendant plusieurs semaines y compris celles d'halloween",
ah, c'est pour ça ! "J'ai fait un simple x wing qui se pose sur la chaise roulante". Mec, un simple x-wing ?
Vieux on n'a pas la même notion de simple. "Si quelqu'un a un fils en chaise roulante
qui serait intéressé pour récupérer le x wing vous êtes le bienvenu". C'est officiellement le meilleur papa de l'univers il n'y a plus de doute !
Oh non, encore une poupée les gars j'en peux, plus nan vraiment. Oh non, c'est glauque... regarde  la photo qui prends... on sait s'il en train
de faire oh là là.
Ça fait rêver qui de rentrée et de voir ça sur son canapé vieux ?
J'ai laissé deux personnes montrer la poupée un de leurs amis ils ne sont jamais revenus à la base cette poupée devait être la mascotte
de mon groupe de post grunge rapport de police a été déposé... Les mecs ont volé une
poupée sexuelle c'est vraiment un délire,
étrange...
Ouais par contre mec la poupée à cinq mille balles : "oui mais c'était la mascotte de mon groupe de rock..." Oui oui oui t'as juste
eu extrêmement honte quand t'as du aller au près des flics que tu t'es fais voler ta poupée sexuelle hein !
On connaît bien la douille. Alors un camion camouflé pour 1800 dollars j'aimerais bien voir ça
mec !
Chanmé  ! Quatre roues motrices intérieur neuf, fenêtres bien nettoyer très peu de kilomètres au compteur
on achète !
Ok là on est tombé sur un gros sadique ! Ils vont juste un emballages vides de toilette avec la photo de toilette sur le devant,
et il dit: " imaginez l'excitation des enfants en voyant un cadeau si gros sous le sapin
rien ne vaut à la fois un tel souvenir et traumatisme". De toute évidence je ferai un jour des blagues à mes enfants, vraiment.
Ok y'a un mec qui propose un service très particulier pour 100 dollars par heure, je
viendrai m'assoir à votre fête à l'endroit de votre choix, je regarderai vos invités pendant toute la durée de l'événement merci et bonne fête
*Musique chelou*
Je veux ce mec, ici, je veux qu'il se mette là, et pour tout la vidéo il regarde la caméra, oh mec !
Le mec vend un
matelas dans lequel il a fait un trou parce que sa femme était enceinte et du coup elle pouvait plus dormir sur le ventre.
Il a troué son put*in de matelas pour que le ventre
rentre dedans et maintenant que sa femme a accouché il vend le matelas parce qu'il sert plus à rien, c'est génial.
Let's f*cking frisbee, qu'est-ce que sa va être cette m*rde ?
Ah, c'est une offre juste pour jouer au frisbee avec lui "peu importe de quelle race ou de quel genre vous êtes, j'essaie pas de racketter ou
de violer quiconque,  tout ce que je veux c'est vous envoyez un putain de frisbee et vous me l'envoyer en retour
et oui je suis très très fort aux lancers et à la réception de frisbee mais ne soyez pas intimider let's do this shit"
*Musique épique*
Mec j'suis ému j'ai envie de faire un Frisbee avec ce mec est bien les amis c'est la fin de cette vidéo sur
les meilleures annonces de Craiglist c'était très amusant !
N'hésitez pas l'aimer si elle vous a plu et
j'adore trouvé, c'est comme les memes tous ces trucs là des fois j'adore juste me poser pendant deux heures et
juste observer
l'ingéniosité ou la connerie des gens ça n'apporterait rien je tu le temps en faisant ça mais putain des fois qu'est ce que je trouve
ça marrant et aux US les mecs sont perchés, ils sont  dans un game futur quoi je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo.
Ohh oui ! C'est la fin du tournage je suis content Lucas, enfin tu t'occupes de moi allez à bientôt !